hello everybody and welcome to part two
of our intermediate Python programming
tutorial series in this video we're
going to be talking about string
operations like string concatenation and
string formatting these are some things
that at least I personally didn't do
very well and I don't think I think when
you're learning basics you just learn
the simplest way to do it so to begin
let's start with a list of names and
we're going to say we've got a Jeff
we've got a Gary we've got a Jill and we
have a Samantha
just for the record I'll try to mention
pip eight the first time that we cover
it but in a list you just have your item
comma space and then spaces around all
equal signs except when you're putting
them in function parameters just for the
record
anyway so those are that's our name our
list of names so if we let's say we want
to iterate over this list and we want to
say hello there and then the name of
this person you might say something like
this like for naming names prin and then
we would say like hello there comma
space or well we could do at this point
we could say plus spaces or enter
closest name like that you could also do
hello there no space and then do a
common name pull this down and you see
hello there Jeff hello there Gary Jill's
method anon so depending on how you talk
to this is either the correct way or the
incorrect way in terms of readability
this is the most correct way because
it's easily understood now there's a
second way to do this and again
depending on who you talk to you there
can be an argument as far as what's the
right way it really doesn't matter you
should just go with what you're more
comfortable with but I'll show you when
the second way is essential so instead
we could say print and trying to satisfy
yeah this'll be fun so print and then
we'll do
a space between the quotations and then
we are going to join and then enjoying
you put a list of things that you're
going to join together and it's a space
will be between these things that we
join so you would write you know hello
there and then a comma and then the name
so I'll comment this out now and then
we'll run it maybe there we go
that took a while see if I can get rid
of that why there we go um okay so you
got L well we didn't we didn't get our
comma but we can just add that in okay
so so it's the same thing but if you ask
me the first one is just so much more
readable and I'm not really sure that
it's worth the performance gain here and
as Python changes over time these are
things like subtle things like these
there really are going to change by
Python even version sometimes so in some
senses this they might be like the
difference is probably just extremely
negligible you'll get away with it but
the difference is when say you've got a
list of strings or really anything and
you want to just print them out as a
string print that list as a string of
course you could do string names and
just print that but let's say instead
you actually want to just print the list
of the names as a string so that might
look something like let me just comment
this out whoops comment this out and
that might look like whoops not again um
we will join just as a comma dot join
and then names is a list so we're fine
let's run that and in fact let's do
comma space there you go so now we've
got Jeff Garry Jill Samantha okay so
that that works is it easily readable if
you know how join works then sure it's
it's it's readable but if you don't know
how join works that's not
beautiful at all but when it comes to
concatenating strings join is preferable
when you're joining more more than two
strings some people will argue that
maybe it's more than like some number of
strings like when the processing changes
but I think it is a general rule of
thumb if you're going to concatenate and
truly concatenate because actually what
we're doing here we are concatenated but
we're still actually kind of doing the
wrong thing in both of these examples
I'll show you the right things soon
enough but probably this isn't even the
right way to go about it but if your
concatenated two or more than two not
252 or more so basically all
concatenation no if you're in
concatenate ignore than two strings you
pie should be using join purely because
it's going to scale better it's going to
use less processing now while we're on
the topic of join I want to show one
more thing that join can be used for or
at least the idea of join so we're going
to go ahead and import OS and then we're
going to say like consider that you have
a file located somewhere so let's say
we've got location of file and I
actually have a file here so to work you
can either create a random text file
somewhere and just put something in the
text file or you can just watch it
doesn't really matter so C colon double
backslash because it's windows doing
windows things so Windows likes to use
back slashes so we use backslash
backslash to escape the backslash
character anyway H backslash backslash
desktop intermediate Python so that's
the location of actually let's say it's
location of files because probably if it
was just a file you would just give the
one off path and you'd be fine but let's
say it's an example where maybe you're
going to iterate through all files in
some sort of OS lister format so you're
listing out the Durer you get the file
names and then you want to open them up
so you're going to start with the
location of the file and then you're
going to grab that file name let's say
the file name
well it is in my case example dot text
it's tempting to let's say we're just
going to print we're not going to open
it right now but it might be tempting to
say location of vials + X let's do the
backslash backslash to be proper here
plus filing so that's really tempting to
do right and then BOOM yeah you've got
the full file path but again that's not
the right way to go about it and a lot
of times especially with join you're
going to have maybe more than this
because each directory could iterate be
its own little string and there's
actually gonna be a lot of times where
you might use that if you are working on
in the in the system itself so you
wouldn't necessarily have a full path
you might be actually joining C :
users H while press C colon slash let's
say you're joining users to H to desktop
to intermediate Python and so on but
this will just be a single join the way
that we can actually do that instead is
you'll see something like this like with
open and then we're going to say Oh s
dot path join it's going to work just
like the other joint only it's just
going to automatically add the little
slashes for us so join look come on man
location of files and then the file name
which has an underscore and then with
open since we're just going to read we
don't have to specify how we're going to
open it so as F and now we're just going
to print F dot read save and run that
and that's the contents so it's just
says o hider great so let's join and we
saw one last thing and that's going to
be string formatting so actually the
location of files that's a that's what
you would do really you would use a join
you're not going to use string
formatting but now this this top one
with Jeff Gary and all that that was
probably that would it make more sense
to use string formatting most likely
with that but I just wanted to show a
really simple example so let's go ahead
and talk about string formatting now
so let's say you want to have a sentence
with the following variables let's say
who equals Gary and then how many will
equal 12 and we're hoping for a sentence
to say something like Gary bought 12
apples today okay where Gary is the
variable and 12 is also a variable so
this can be really tempting to do the
following like in fact let's do sentence
equals something and then we'll just
print the sentence so let's say you know
you might want to say like Pooh comma
bot comma how many comma let's add the
spaces everything will be Pepe guys
actually we need this to go in the print
statement the format will work but this
won't work so anyways who bought how
many and then we'll say apples and then
space today all right so we can run that
and that might be one way you might also
rather than the commas you might add the
spaces and then use the plus tweets his
own but that's wrong and once upon time
you could use the percent s for string
formatting and that was thought to be
the best way to do it that's no more
instead what we have are the curly
braces why did he do that interesting I
don't know what that's a comment so the
fact that it would air there no that's
interesting why is that happening
anyway um not they're just on the
comment anyway idle typical so the real
way you should do this is prints and
then you would say just empty brackets
space bot empty brackets apples today
and then you will say dot format
and then just throw it in all the
parameters in this case we just have to
which is who and how many so we can run
that and we should get the same sentence
good so both of them Gary about 12
apples today this is for the moment the
correct way to do string formatting if
you're following along and you're in
Python 2 you have to give like values
like so one in two I think it'll work in
3 now that's not going to work I wonder
if I have to put this I'm not sure how
to do it too but just know if you're
following along it to stop that upgrade
to 3 but if you refuse there's something
specific about Python 2 with string
formatting see if I can find it really
quick come on someone give me an example
so oh I said one - ok yeah duh all right
so 0 1 let's run it boom ok so you can
do 0 1 so in theory you could say
instead 1 0 and let's see if the
functionality runs through misses yeah
12 baht Gary apples today so you if you
want to do order I'm not sure why you
would really need to do that I guess
it's a little more explicit but it's
unnecessary if you ask me but in Python
2 you'll have to use the index values I
can't believe I tried one - come on
anyway I need to go back to the basics
and learn that list start with zero with
anyway
okay so let's string formatting and why
you should upgrade to Python 3 so you'd
have to put numbers in the curly braces
every month so anyway that's enough on
string formatting since I have it up I
mean there is a ton of stuff you can do
first of all you can upgrade 3 oh yeah
looking good
ok so there's a ton of stuff that we can
do with string formatting what I just
showed you was like really basic but
these this is these are two things that
I see violated the most and I personally
violated the
it's myself just concatenation with
pluses or commas
especially with file names I was really
happy when I found out Oh s Pat so join
also just string formatting with the
curly braces that works I think it's
very readable that's the way to go
that's the most scalable way so that
string formatting that's all for now if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise til the next video